if you like your laughs with the splash
of the red stuff chances are you can
already quote every line from Fargo
accent and all and you think about
Heather's whenever you get a slushie
I love this god let's go get a slushie
well plenty of dark comedies are
bonafide classics there are a slew of
other nuanced hilarious and joyfully
destructive movies that may have slipped
under your radar here are some
lesser-known dark comedies that'll have
you laughing the pain away Arsenic and
Old Lace it's a classic of the sub-genre
but many younger movie lovers have
missed out on the incredible 1944 dark
comedy Arsenic and Old Lace the movie
stars Cary Grant as Mortimer Brewster a
pretty normal guy who is shocked to
learn that his two elderly aunts have
developed a nasty habit of slaying all
their gentleman callers the movie which
is based on the play of the same name by
Joseph Kesselring is entirely bizarre
from start to finish with pitch-black
jokes that still hold up today while the
Brewster family is definitely not one
you'd want to be a part of their lethal
antics make for a timeless dark comedy
Barton Fink important thing is we all
want to have that Barton Fink feeling
and I guess we all have that bottom
feeling but since you're Barton think
I'm assuming you have it in spades the
Coen brothers have written and directed
several classic dark comedies and
although you've likely seen many of
their films there are still some hidden
gems in their filmography this includes
the haunting Lisa real 1991 film Barton
Fink which features John Turturro as a
playwright who discovers the seedy side
of Hollywood when he takes a job writing
for a movie studio as tutor OHS Barton
Fink quickly learns the hotel he's
staying at is more than just a dump it's
also home to a brutal madman who seems
to be targeting people close to Barton
John Goodman stars in the film as Fink's
a unique neighbor while Tony Shalhoub
also makes an early career appearance
plus a blood bath like Fargo and lacking
the laugh-out-loud sensibilities of the
big lebowski Burton Fink is a comedic
and yet deadly serious tale of writer's
block and the class
Faustian bargain in other words it's a
thinking man's dark comedy in Bruges
Colin Farrell is a hit man with a
conscience in Martin McDonnells
2008 dark comedy action film in Bruges
the movie features Ferrell in a golden
globe-winning performance as ray a
hitman who retreats with his mentor Ken
to Bruges Belgium after a hit gone wrong
you are weird give it some cocaine the
movie which earned an Oscar nomination
for Best Original Screenplay also
features great supporting performances
from rape fines as raise boss Harry and
Clements Posey as his love interest
Chloe although there are plenty of funny
moments the movie is really a story
about redemption slipping a strong
message and a surprisingly insightful
examination of mortality under the veil
of humor Ingrid goes west
Aubrey Plaza's Instagram Envy goes up
the rails in Ingrid goes west which
features the former perks and recreation
star as Ingrid a troubled young woman
who decides to move out west and
befriend LA socialite Taylor played by
Elizabeth Olsen they quickly forge a
bond but the facade soon begins to crack
leading to a darkly funny conclusion
Ingrid goes west definitely pushes the
boundaries of comedy luring the line
between personal trauma and dark humour
while the movie features impressive
backup performances from Olsen O'Shea
Jackson jr. and Wyatt Russell
it's Plaza who really shines showing
that her acting range goes far beyond
parks April Ludgate
Ingrid goes West will make you laugh but
with Plaza at the helm it'll also give
you all the fields what's your biggest
emotional wound what it's our question
of the day what we do in the shadows
when you're a vampire you become very
sexy Taika Waititi is what we do in the
shadows is a vampire movie for people
who hate vampire movies the film follows
the movements of four vampire roommates
played by WA TT Jemaine Clement Jonathan
brew and bin Fran sham as seen through
the lens of a documentary crew the four
vampires in question all lived together
and they have the
same conflicts that any human roommates
would have is thinkin that you have not
done the dishes for five years it's
unacceptable to have so many bloody
dishes all over this bench like there
things get even more tense for the
roommates when they have to deal with
the newly turned Nick who's reckless
behavior threatens to expose their
secrets putting a human touch on the
film makes the movie a very different
take on the vampire genre and what T T's
always on point sense of humour makes it
a coffin full of laughs from start to
finish
slither written and directed by
guardians of the galaxy's James Gunn the
horror comedy slither features a group
of small town residents dealing with the
sudden appearance of an alien parasite
that has the ability to take over
people's bodies and minds this is just
the beesting fans of guardians of the
galaxy will be familiar with the film's
antagonist Michael Rooker who plays
yondu in the MCU Rooker is incredible as
the infected grant grant Elizabeth Banks
co-stars providing broker's solid backup
as his clever wife Starla the movie also
features an impressive performance from
the always charming Nathan Fillion
making it a thoroughly enjoyable if
pretty damn gross horror ride
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too
[Music]